Uh, cause money. They like money.
Everything we do is this is where my tech nerd side comes in.
Everything they do is to keep people on that platform longer and to keep them
looking at more ads and watching more videos and earning them more ad revenue,
they have no reason to get rid of 70 something, million people like this.
Like they're not going to infinity Wars us because they like our money.
You know, they like our eyeballs. They want to do it.
So I don't think it's going to happen.
Make some sense of all this stuff.
Like I'm always looking around when I find voices that seem kind of sane and
interesting and like somewhat trustworthy. How do you find people?
Cause people always come up. People literally come up to me at the supermarket.
They'll be like, Dave, you're the only one I trust. And I'm always like, well,
we got a big problem here.
People say that to me too. They're like,
you're the only one that tells the truth. And I really pride myself on that.
I'll keep telling him the truth and throwing in my silliness.
And the fun part is that I love being wrong because then I get to learn the
right thing. So I don't even care if I'm wrong, but I trust.
I'd say I trust you. I trust Ben Shapiro minus 10%.
Cause I'll just make up for the facility. Cause it's in there. Um,
I trust Rogan's show Joe Rogan's show. Um,
and it's not even that I trust their opinions.
I just trust that they like to learn.
So his guests and him they'll work their way through. I like that.
I trust Erica,
who is the CEO of Barstool sports and pretty much the whole Barstool
sports crew. I think they tell it like it is to Dan.
Crazy. That Barstool has to be so involved in politics though. Right?
It's really funny. It's really, really funny.
And this is why I'm saying the pendulum's coming back. When this,
the people who were supposed to be serious, I've got crazy.
Then the crazies are going to have to take over and we're running the asylum and
we have more experience. This is the thing they don't,
they don't get it they're out. And when we go crazy,
we're going to be way better than them.
But are you afraid that if Trump does not pull off this stuff with the
lawsuits and stuff and Biden becomes president that at that point,
why wouldn't big tech, just get rid of all of us, you know,
they're calling us all Nazis anyway,
the entire political establishment will say you're a bunch of Nazi Trump
supporters, big tech. Well, I don't like to say it publicly,
obviously.
Okay. I was, I was under the impression this on YouTube.
Oh, okay. All right. Yeah. I'm so sorry. Like I thought you were like gay Nazi.
Yeah, my bad.
But, but really like, are, are you afraid of that? That like, why wouldn't,
you know, you've built your life and career and all that goodness.
On the two on the pipes of YouTube and Facebook and Twitter and Instagram and
all that. Like, are you worried that, you know,
January 20 rolls around Biden's president and within the next couple of weeks,
like why would big tech not just boot everybody deplorable and a bad guy in a
Nazi and the rest of it?
Uh, cause money, they like money.
Everything we do is this is where my tech nerd side comes in.
Everything they do is to keep people on that platform longer and to keep them
looking at more ads and watching more videos and earning them more ad revenue,
they have no reason to get rid of 70 something. Million people like this.
Like they're not going to infinity Wars us because they like our money.
You know, they're like our eyeballs. They want to do it.
So I don't think it's going to happen. It's not in their best interests.
And this is what I hope. TV hop, TV network,
TV networks learn too many thoughts at once. Red bull, um,
slowdown woman. I'm trying, I'm trying,
there's playing to one side and there's 70 other million people to entertain
you. Dumb asses. Guess what? All those people do. They buy toilet paper,
they buy makeup. They buy hair products. You clearly do. Wow. Um,
it's it's wow. It's amazing.
We tore it together. I mean the hair game, if we toured together,
would you seriously, like.
Let's just have our hair on. T-shirts like just that lens of our hair.
That'd be fine. Dave, Nicole.
And Dave. That's my brother's name too. So it's fun. Um, yeah.
I just think it would be really stupid of them economically to not start playing
to the other half of America and North America.
People forget that Canadians very much follow American politics and chime in on
it because we're attached. Wear your hat and uh, yeah.
What's going on with what's going on with your guy up there. Trudeau,
you must love that guy. Huh?
That robot malfunctioned a while ago.
We got to like hear hearing him in between
doing black face, telling us how to be good.
People is just it's too much for me. He talks in a fake robot voice.
Now it's it's just too much.
How did he, how did he win a reelection?
Like cause most Western countries and now it's a little up in the air with us,
but in the last like five years, most Western countries, they,
they went to the right, but you guys,
you went the other way and now he's talking great reset.
The humanoid that he is.
Reset. Okay. Bring it. Um,
which is probably why I get at least a hundred people asking me every day to run
for prime minister and they're not kidding. And I've had financial backers.
They asked me if I would do it, they want me to run for governor of California.
Now you see what you say? How stupid is this?
I mean, Arnold kind of broke the mold for us like years ago.
So that's pretty good, but I don't want to be prime minister.
The salary cap is 180,000 Canadian that's frankly like, nah,
you know, for all that pressure, that's like $23 American got into it.
Um, but yeah, that takes me down another tangent.
What do you think of Trudeau? Like, like what,
what is happening in Canada? He's going to.
Be out soon. The thing is we just didn't care enough.
Canadians follow American politics more than we follow
Canadian politics. It just is what it is. Yours is more entertaining.
It's more fun. The characters are better. It's a good reality show.
Ours is kind of like why, why? And we're too polite.
There's not a lot of fighting in our house of commons and we just kind of let
things skirt by until suddenly this is talking about the great reset and his
robot voice. Um,
then it's getting a little weird and he's fighting with the premier of Ontario
about giving the cash advances to small businesses that they promised over a
month ago. Then I'm like, okay, who's who we tagging in here.
Cause now someone has to go take this guy out like election wise.
Not like take him out. Yeah.
I got it. You're not calling for the assassination of Justin.
Calling for the assassination of Justin Trudeau. Facebook. Did you hear that?
Okay. I've gotten in trouble for jokes before.
Listen, the media matters people.
They watch this show with a keen eye waiting for me to pause the wrong way or
for one of my guests to accidentally say something because Skype freaked out for
a moment. So we have to be very careful. You do not want Justin. Yeah.
These people are pathetic, ridiculous fools.
Oh, tell me,
you should really think at least they didn't send you to your fiery death to
rescue horses that were fine.
You see, there you go. You wait, do you guys think it's a little weird?
You guys, you Canadians, we don't really understand you people up North.
Do you guys think it's weird? The way that, that we,
that it seems like our issues have been imported into Canadian shores because
every gig that I did in Canada and when I was with Jordan and when I've done
solo gigs,
people are crazed and starving for the types of things that I talk about.
And I did an event with, um, Maxime Bernier,
who was the people's party of Canada, you know,
basically the libertarian candidate for prime minister.
And we did an event and Antifa was there and they were throwing things and
attacking us and screaming, Nazi that video.
You probably saw that video of the woman with the Walker,
trying to cross the street.
That was tough for me to come to Canada to talk about free speech, like insane.
But, but,
and then you have all these people in there screaming black lives matter and all
this stuff. And it's like, well,
is there a problem with police shootings in Canada?
And does it have anything to do with race?
And then you ask them and they're like, no, no. That's like, well, what,
what are you screaming about?
No, just we want to play. Yeah. We want to play too.
Like literally I just, when Canadians start going off issues,
I laugh most of the time because I would say our number one issue.
If we have issues outside of pandemic and stuff like that is environmental it's
where are we going to lay pipeline? Uh, for natural oil? What, you know,
indigenous lands, can we go through? What's not cool. Let's,
let's make peace with the indigenous indigenous people.
Those are the real issues Canadians have. And I'd say,
number one is environmental. Other than that, we're kind of chill.
And I think that makes some people antsy.
So they make up problems just like everyone else in the world.
They have nothing to complain about it. So they make it up.
I just remembered something. I don't think I told you. Did I ever,
did I ever tell you that I messaged you while you were in Hamilton,
Ontario during all that, and that was for that gig, right?
Yeah. I didn't know you yet, but I saw that that was happening.
And I reached out to,
I think on Instagram and I offered you another venue with a ton of
security. Yeah. If you ever need help in Hilton.
This is going to sound very. I don't run my Instagram.
That's okay. It does, but it's okay.
No, I mean, I got a guy that runs it and sometimes messages,
sometimes things slip through. Well, I appreciate it. I mean,
that thing really was, I was like, I cannot believe this is happening in Canada.
I got people screaming that I'm a Nazi, the three speakers on stage.
You had a Christian or Jew and a Muslim on stage or they're screaming that it's
a white supremacist event.
You guys failed at white supremacy. So hard. Yes.
Hard. So hard. Hitler would be Hitler would be very, very disappointed.
So I was about to ask you what's next for you, but I think we know what's next,
which is you got some sort of late night situation coming. That's awesome.
I do. And it's going to be fun.
And I know I sound a little like evil villain about it, but that's how I feel.
I feel like, okay, you guys want to play, you pushed good people this far,
the people's champions are rising up. We're going to swing.
And I can't just be like, Oh, it's just me. I'm going to take on everybody.
There's a fricking X-Men crew rising up right now. And man,
I feel bad for SNL.
I feel bad for these people that are stuck in the little boxes.
Can't say what they want. Can't be real comics because yeah,
the good ones are coming.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about comedy,
instead of the nonstop yelling, you get everywhere else,
check out our comedy playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
check out our full episode playlist,
they're both right over here and you get notified of all future videos.
Be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.